mais de quoi on va se parler aujourd'hui
on se parle de ça c'est le nouveau
samsung galaxy buzz pro alors je vous le
dis tout de suite je l'assumé je le dis
le studio est en train d'être refait
donc tout a été péter donc on tourne
aujourd'hui devant un fond vert c'est
pour ça que c'est un petit peu bizarre
donc aujourd'hui on va se parler de ses
tout nouveaux bugs qu'on présentait sa
leçon qu'il n'ya pas très longtemps en
même temps que ses nouveaux smartphones
de la gamme galaxy s 21 on s'en parle
très rapidement à commencer par samsung
galaxy s 21 ultra donc ça s'est super je
n'avais donc à venir vous abonner tout
de suite si ce n'est pas déjà fait comme
ça vous serez tous et on va se
concentrer dès aujourd'hui sur les
samsung galaxy s pro et de la réduction
proactive
on a deux haut parleurs à intérieur
notamment 2,3 micron d'un produit qui
est super sympa qui fait très jolies
promesses
[Musique]
thibauld trouvailles en laisse vous les
prenez vous les prenez votre oreille
vous tourner ça se positionne
extrêmement facilement ça c'est un truc
que j'aime bien qui est très très très
important vous savez c'est effectivement
de tout de suite trouvé la bonne taille
ce qui vous convient ce qui ne vous
convient pas ce qui est fait pour vous
bon je les enlève parce que comme il la
réduction de bruit passive à savoir qui
va être obstrués votre canal auditif
le son ne rentre pas en tout cas une
partie du son ne rentre pas ce qui déjà
vous isole de l'extérieur ça c'est bien
d'autant plus au delà de la réduction de
bruit active mais ça je vous le
développent dans quelques instants donc
en termes de confort personnellement je
les aime bien je trouve que là dessus
samsung a plutôt très bien bossé
une fois de plus et ça ça dépendra de la
morphologie de chacun des personnes chez
qui cette typologie de bugs irons et la
deutsch et qui s'alliera absolument pas
donc vous voyez vraiment à trouver la
tailles d'embouts qui vous correspond
alors soyez tranquille là dessus puisque
à l'intérieur de votre boîte vous avez
des petites tailles d'embouts
différentes qui vont s'adapter à vos
oreilles la tenue en oreille est très
bonne le confort et là on les sent pas
particulièrement lorsqu'on est garde ses
oreilles pendant un petit moment donc
pour moi la celui-là
la mission est remplie de la part de
samsung vous avez en plus une
certification ip67 il ya vous certifier
protéger contre la pluie contre la sueur
on est vraiment pour l'idée de
l'intempérie vous partez dehors vous
écoutez de la musique il se met à
pleuvoir
vous êtes protégé vous faites un peu de
sport vous courrez avec vous avez de la
transpiration normalement et bien vous
n'aurai absolument aucun problème là
dessus
donc ça c'est bien je trouve très très
très bien profilée il sent que la
solidité leur robustesse plutôt élégant
avoue meilleur d'ailleurs vous dès
maintenant ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire pour connecter vos galaxy
s pro à votre smartphone vous n'avez up
cas les ouvrir et sont reconnus
automatiquement il vous affiche le
niveau de batterie des écouteurs
également du bon ok c'est très pratique
on va rentrer tout de suite dans le dur
en parlant de la réduction bruit active
parce que si c'est une des promesses qui
est fait par samsung vous avez des
écouteurs avec ce qu'ils appellent eux à
lc active noise cancelling c'est la
réduction de bruit active
vous avez donc deux types de réduction
de bruit si la première c'est la
réduction de bruit passive à savoir
lorsque vous allez venir poser vos buzz
ça vaut obstruent le canal auditif ça
vous bloque donc déjà de certains sons
extérieurs mécaniquement en plus de ça
vous avez de la réduction d'objectif qui
fonctionne avec pas moins de trois
micros ça va devenir capter le son
extérieur ça va le comparer par rapport
aux sons qui à l'intérieur de votre
oreille et qui vont venir les annuler
rapport aux micros qui est situé à
l'intérieur c'est un système de hors
phases tout simplement pour voir qu'on
est sur des bugs et pas sur un casque la
réduction bruit active fonctionne plutôt
bien ça dépendra une fois de plus du
positionnement je trouve assez efficace
je trouve pas aussi efficace que
l'airpod pro d'apple mais ça se joue à
pas grand chose
vraiment un pas grand chose en plus ce
qui est sympa ici vous avez deux niveaux
de réduction collective soit une qui est
élevé soit une qui est faible pour
connecter vos écouteurs vous allez dans
votre application qui s'appelle galaxie
ware et bull qui se situe juste ici vous
voyez c'est niveau de batterie de vos
deux bugs vous pouvez gérer ici la
suppression de bruit suppression active
de bruit soit un niveau élevé soit un
niveau faible
moi je vous conseille quand même de
rester sur le niveau élevé vous pouvez
carrément la désactiver si vous
souhaitez ou alors carrément passé sur
le son environnement et là vous avez
quatre niveaux soit un tout petit peu
son environnement vous allez lire
injectés dans vos haut-parleurs vous
pouvez le monte moyen élevé où il a
carrément très élevé et là vous entendez
une espèce de voix de robot est ce que
ça va venir faire c'est capté le sont
toujours à l'extérieur avec vos deux
micros et venir vous l'injecter dans le
haut parleur pour vous captez vraiment
tout ce qui se passe autour de vous et
pour être vraiment aux aguets bien vous
soyez en ville que vous alliez marché
traversée courir ou quoi que ce soit
vous êtes conscient de ce qui se passe
autour de vous une fois de plus à voir
en fonction de vous de là où vous êtes
de ce que vous voulez entendre comme
niveaux de bruits extérieurs
il ya un autre système qu'ils ont mis en
place que celui intégré l'année dernière
sur son double 20 h musique salle 4 ça
va être ce qu'ils appellent le mode
conversation le mode commerce assure par
exemple vous avez mis la réduction de
bruit active même pas pourquoi pas vous
êtes dans un café dans un restaurant par
exemple vous avez quelque chose à
emporter et vous vous mettez à pareille
oui bonjour je voudrais bien si je
voudrais bien ça eh bien c'est pas vous
mettre le son environnement pour vous
captier ce qui se passe à l'extérieur et
pouvoir venir converser avec la personne
en face de vous moi personnellement ce
genre de choses n'arrive pas à
l'utiliser quand j'arrive devant
quelqu'un qu'est ce que je fais je les
enlève
je trouve ça déjà d'une plus polis
peut-être que dans le temps les années
passent on est bien on va s'habituer au
fait de garder ces bugs et communiquer
comme ça voilà moi je ne suis pas
extrêmement convaincu aujourd'hui des
arbitres le mois en bas en commentaire
ça peut vous tentez surtout que vous
voyez un intérêt un usage nous alors
absolument pas marqué le moindre
commentaire
mais là où ça devient intéressant
puisqu'on parle de dos et bien c'est de
parler de qualité aux
you est ici vous et retraite à moins de
deux haut parleurs dans chaque écouteur
le premier surfeur de 11 pouces qui est
là pour restituer les graves et l'autre
côté vous avez un tweeter de 6,5 pouces
qui est là pour les aigus les deux vont
travailler de concert pour fabriquer les
seconds intermédiaires que sont les
médiums médium grave médiums aigus mais
vous avez donc deux canaux séparés ce
qui permettra d'avoir un son qui va être
beaucoup plus précis puisque vous
n'allez pas avoir un seul et même
haut-parleurs qui va travailler pouvons
faire tout le spectre audio
donc on va gagner en précision au niveau
des aiguilles on va gagner en rondeur au
niveau des graves
maintenant quand vous l'écoutez lui
remet en place n'a pas égalé son flat
sens absolument aucune correction au
niveau d'un équaliseur je trouve assez
bien très honnêtement je trouve bien sûr
tout ce qui va être médium grave médiums
aigus aiguë ça me va parfaitement bien
vous avez de la précision au niveau des
cymbales vous retrouvez tous vos
instruments d'un monde et guitare vous
avez des attaques vous avez une vraie
présence au niveau de la voix vous avez
aussi un peu de corps au niveau de votre
voix grâce aux médias le drame parce
qu'il a manqué ici un petit peu c'est un
son un peu plus grave un peu plus basse
fatalement on est sur des petits bugs
même s'ils ont un goût fort de conspuer
ça reste quand même petit on va pas
développer un gros sortiront rhône avec
des petits bugs ça c'est normal
ce qu'il faut donc faire c'est
télécharger l'application galaxie
wearable vous aurez accès à votre
équaliseur pour choisir le type de sous
qui vous intéresse et qui vous
correspond savard et simon égaliseur
pour venir régler des bandes de
fréquences mode normal vous êtes
complètement plat ampli basse vous
voulez monter vraiment les basses mais
ça bave un petit peu c'est pas terrible
secousse à dimanche et le reste du
spectre je suis pas très fan léger
claire et amplification des aigus
personnellement je ne suis pas fan ce
que jamais ce que je recommande c'est le
dynamique soit normal soit dynamique
la qualité audio pour moi est très bonne
samsung a rempli son pari donc si vous
voulez des écouteurs qui fonctionne bien
avec une bonne écoute
avec une bonne réduction de bruit les
galaxies vote pro sont très cool vous
avez jusqu'à 18 heures d'autonomie avec
votre petite boîte l'art vous connaissez
le principe je vais rien vous apprendre
je pense que vous connaissez l'histoire
chaque petit buzz à sa propre autonomie
et ensuite vous les mettez dans leur
petit étui et les tue l'avenir les
recharger et qu'on est hui évident et
bien vous rechargez l'étui en usb c'est
ou alors directement sans fil dans les
deux cas ces pratiques à vous de voir
quels sont les usages qui vous
corresponde au mieux
mais là dessus pour moi rien à redire
autre point qui est bien qui est très
intuitif ce sont les commandes tactiles
alors les commandes tactiles je vous
explique vous appuyer une fois planes et
puis une autre fois pose très simple
lorsque vous écoutez de la musique vous
appuyé deux fois morceau suivant lorsque
le téléphone sonne et qu'on veut nous
rejoindre vous appuyé deux fois
vous décrochez vous appuyé deux fois
vous raccrochez lorsque vous écoutez la
musique vous appuyez trois fois morceaux
précédents voyez c'est extrêmement
intuitif on comprendrait
bien après vous allez les appuis
prolongeant les appuis prolonger son
intéressant vous avez deux possibilités
la première pouvait venir régler
l'action vous voulez dans votre appui
prolongé que ça c'est intéressant parce
que ça permet de venir régler les
commandes que j'aborde directement sur
les écouteurs notamment sur le buzz de
gauche là sur le boeuf droit buzz gauche
je peux me dire par exemple je peux
venir permuter son contrôle de bruit
passé de la suppression active de bruit
aux sons environnants soit m bixby soit
volume bas soit spotify
regardez ça c'est très très intéressant
parce que si je le mets permuter le
contrôle de bruit et que je veux aller
par exemple sur volume bas et bien ça ne
les volumes ou de l'autre côté tac en
laissant impliqué longtemps sur le buzz
gauche je vais baisser le son et en
appuyant longtemps sur le buzz droit je
vais monter le son mais si par exemple
seulement monter le son le père muté son
nom contrôle de bruit eh bien je ne peux
pas ça me paraîtrait logique de me dire
ok je vais venir monter et baisser le
son c'est ce que je te suis parce que
j'écoute de la musique mais je vais
aussi pouvoir perd 1,8 et mon contrôle
de bruit intelligent et l'avarié bon
voilà ça c'est un truc qui est un petit
peu dommage il a fallu aller un peu plus
loin je ne sais pas quelle serait la
bonne solution tout de suite mais voyez
ça c'est un petit point de regrets que
je vais avoir après spotify bixby très
honnêtement c'est ce que vous le dire
ces accessoires
je m'en fiche mais vous pouvez également
lorsque quelqu'un vient vous appelez en
faisant un appui prolongé refusé l'appel
et envoyer la personne directement sur
votre répondeur vous avez également un
mode s'appelle le mode auto switch si
par exemple vous utilisez une samsung
galaxy tab est sept premiers regarder
vos films vos séries etc et que votre
téléphone sonne et bien qu'est-ce qui se
passe vos écouteurs vont basculer
directement sur votre téléphone que vous
puissiez prendre votre appel et lorsque
j'ai terminé vous raccrochez vous allez
repartir exactement sur votre tablette
c'est un mode qui pratique quel délit
dans auto switch j'aime beaucoup
après il ya plein d'autres petites
options qui sont assez sympa à lecture à
deux voix des notifications pourquoi pas
c'est un petit truc en plus avancé vous
allez avoir le 2 360 pourquoi pas
amélioration de l'audition en fait c'est
un panoramique un droite gauche
voyez ces galaxies ball seront pleins de
jolis qualité 229 euros
dites moi s'il pourrait vous intéresser
les accessoires qui marchera vraiment
bien avec vos samsung galaxy s 21 a
d'ailleurs dit man vous ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
samsung galaxy 2 buzz buzz plus buzz
live ou pas est-ce que vous avez déjà
des petits bugs et est-ce que c'est
samsung galaxy 2 trop brèves ou fermer
l'oeil personnellement j'aime beaucoup
sauf que samsung attrait
bien bossé jeu sorti un produit qui est
très cohérent qui est très bien
équilibré avec un sont signés à kg parce
que oui vous le savez samsung a racheté
à calais il ya quelques années j'ai déjà
raconté un petit peu l'histoire donc on
a un son qui est il peut en un sont
qualité invention qui est bien équilibré
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire et quant à nous on
se retrouve très vite pour parler
d'audio de teck pour cette espèce sur
tous les nouveaux samsung galaxy et
notamment en premier le samsung galaxy s
21 ultra et ça c'est très très cool